I was since I was a little girl I
believed in fairy tales and magic and
all that kind of thing when it came time
to come up with a saying or phrase to
validate black wanted to speak about
greatness like girls on magic is made
sense to me
[Music]
listen I envision is women who are black
plumbers specific just making a way out
of no way
are you coming into their own thin
self-sufficient
extraordinarily some and just being
amazing under all success in any
circumstances right anything you could
possibly think of a black women have
been able to do it and do it in a way
that makes take me up but I hear black
girl magic I see golds women confident
women and women that are also able to be
vulnerable but also getting who they are
and be confident and they are laughter
Oh magic is complete feminine power
complete goddess power capping and fear
melanin in your DNA its activate your
ancestors to activate your true self
purpose of being your I'm gonna be an
amazing and embodying that in every way
possible I think just black girl the
black six girls like trans girls he's
doing what feels good for them I hope
they're so proud of no silly it's just
it's so important to me that we feel
validated in uplifting this because it's
so many negatives out there I want to
always be able to have something
positive to hold on supply assumes I
think it's the way we walk I think it's
the way we dress I think Michael magic
is something a spark almost something
extra low hum that we put into
everything that we do usually a black
women you see all of my culture micro
magic is ability to overcome the ability
to do like amazing box a [ __ ] with like
very little a black girl Marrakesh take
is about celebration and triumph or
struggle but it's not just one is all
those things because we encompass all
those things we are those builders
episode through our celebrations and all
the happiness and joy the experience and
all those things that come along with in
you know multi-dimensional human
everything comes of all of me more than
just one thing
[Music]